the captain of the clutch and boomer of
esports heco has announced his
retirement from competition after such a
long career he will be moving full time
to content creation with hundred thieves
so let's take a look back at his career
and also the team he has left behind
[Music]
all right y'all before we get into the
video i have to remind you as always hit
the like button the subscribe button and
to ring the notification bell all right
y'all bring out the tissues and put on
your best dad hats the one and the only
spencer heco martin is putting down the
competition gloves for good hunter
thieves announced on april 12th that
heco would be stepping down from
competitive valerian hey guys it's hiko
here and today i am announcing my
retirement from professional valerie
when i first started playing valorant i
wasn't really sure if i wanted to remain
a streamer or actually go pro in
valorant and try to play competitive
valorent when i did make the decision
that i wanted to though there were a lot
of organizations that had reached out to
me to
possibly make a team for them and it
seemed like pretty much for since day
one
my vision aligned the most with hundred
thieves now my first thought was are you
kidding me but no hiko is actually
retiring people offered one final salute
to oh captain my captain as he stepped
down for good others like dapper in a
rather tongue-in-cheek way offered their
tributes as well asana left us with the
realization that there was now only one
player left from the hundred thieves
first strike roster and that the mantle
of hunter thieves valerant future was
now officially passed on to him from
boomer to zoomer one of the first old
school cs go meets new school valent
roster now has been completely
overhauled shazam also offered his
insight as to why this might have
happened now that makes sense dude this
stream's like
at the level my stream is uh at a
certain point you realize like well
you just don't have the passion for
competing like it's just better for your
future to stream so it was a pretty
bittersweet day for both young and old
esports fans hiko has had a 14-year
career which now that i'm thinking about
it might be as old as some of you why
are you watching can you do your
homework i know for us valor and plebs
it is a sad day for the literal boomer
of the scene to leave us but we have to
remember that our counter-strike friends
were blessed with hiko much longer than
us hiko actually started his career in
cs go in 2012 but played some
counter-strikes starting in 2010. i was
learning algebra in middle school while
hiko was starting a long storied career
from 2012 to 2019 heco cs go clear left
us with some unforgettable moments like
this clutch that cemented his reputation
garrett is going to be waiting hiko
charges in dust and check
oh my god inhuman reactions he was a
part of a lot of different teams since
2011 leaving his signature mark on all
of them and as a part of team liquid he
pulled this off at mlg columbus 2016 and
came oh so close to a major title now
again as we've seen so many times before
it's down to hika but against four is it
really possible we do have a few players
quite tagged up here from luminosity so
he could definitely not going down
without a fight oh wow there's the first
boss drag heco gets a double there's
still two players left they got no
health on them 13 and three heco
creeping around the site now there's
still time oh my goodness how did he do
this how does he go do it again
he helped his team secure a top four
finish at cs go's first ever major and
saw himself on the other side of our
favorite thing to talk about on this
channel the jumping up if you ever want
to feel exhausted take a gander at the
list of every single competition hiko
has competed in in cs go he truly put
his nose to the grindstone for that game
which is why he had an almost
decade-long career that solidified him
as an icon to borrow words from my
colleague dimitri regarded as one of
north america's longest-standing og
top-tier talents he is known to be one
of the smartest players his region has
ever seen in 2020 he came over to
valerian and stuck with 100 thieves
where he was able to raise a trophy
above his head at first strike it might
have been a whole new game for hiko
after years of cs go but one thing still
remain true
he could absolutely pop off
black person not be able to speed space
shade off's good for wine we go
trades one out oh just narrowly not able
to get the second pitch again he's able
to get a second one heco 24 health
running for playing this chronicle
has plenty of health chronicle on the
tab
he's got it rose don't fake he's got to
get it to happen
he gets four he gets the red bull clutch
heco was part of the team from the very
beginning the team was literally built
around him hiko was the very first
member of 100 thieves ballerin and then
everyone else came after teammates came
and went but heco remained the team's
rock he really was the core of a hundred
thieves valorent 1v2 for hiko 15 hp how
many times has eco been in situations
my man
situations just like this in a 1vx low
health he's got some utility and he
makes magic happen once again this time
on the international stage does he have
it in them does that gene
work here in berlin you've got the two
members of hobon liberty creeping their
way forward he goes good for one the 1v1
he's gonna get info the tap's not there
he hasn't even gotten it to happen
baby spencer martin does it again a red
bull clutch for 100 thieves so when he
go announced his retirement it really
hit home for a lot of people hiko had a
14-year career full of ups and downs
that we as fans clung onto every last
bit of it is literally the end of an era
but as they say as one chapter ends
another one is able to begin or continue
in this case even as he was beginning
his career as a pro valorem streamer
hiko was the go-to place for valerian
die hards the game caused his stream to
explode and although he will not be in
the server anymore chances are his
significance to the growth of the game n
a is not going anywhere when valerian's
pro scene first started hiko was one of
the first big time n a names to move
over and back then on this very channel
we hypothesized about whether or not
valorem would just be a place where not
good enough cs players got exiled to hey
hey i didn't work here then do not come
for me i didn't say that i think right
now with this move in mind it's pretty
clear that there is a whole crop of
rising talent ready to take over he goes
protege asana at the forefront hiko will
be moving over to content creation full
time and i am glad our captain gets to
rest while doing something he is
actually really good at you can still
watch hiko on a stream reading patch
notes to viewers and pulling up clutches
like he does best
i'm fun
oh my god one is uh
standing ahead
foreign
one enemy remaining
[Applause]
little insight i will literally start my
mornings with hiko stream and a cup of
coffee and i 100 recommend you join me
it is the best as for the hunter thieves
valerent roster we know it will be asana
left standing with bang and newcomers
will derek and stellar heco has said
that he is excited to see the roster
play we however will just have to wait
to see how they will perform but let's
give one last chef's kiss to our captain
shall we for all time's sake
like there's so many bad people in
esports and hiko's just so nice
i'm starting to tear up
this oh man he go
dude heco started playing 14 years ago
what do you know i was doing 14 years
ago
learning algebra